[Music]
my water actually broke right now i'm
timing contractions not forever you were
earlier how are you feeling with my wife
[Music]
oh my goodness i did it you guys
i did it
[Music]
oh my god
4am baby was born at
2 34.
i did it with no pain medication the
contractions just came out of nowhere
are you ready to see baby
look at this new daddy hi
and look at his son we have a boy you
guys it's a boy it's a boy oh my
goodness we have a boy
hi bubba i know you're hungry
oh look at that face that isaac used to
make that exact same face i remember
that face you're so precious
you did so good my buddy so how was it
the labor for you it was fast because
like i didn't recognize myself like i
was yelling at the top of my lungs at
one point like when the head was like
crowning
and they were telling me to push and
like they were telling me like tuck your
chin and hold your breath but baby's
here baby's healthy oh luckily thank god
the baby doesn't have to go to the nicu
because they're saying that he's
pre-term so he's technically considered
a creamy baby
and so they were saying like if he's not
able to breathe properly or like not
meet certain criteria that he would have
spend time in the nicu with thank god
he's okay
he weighs five pounds
18 point something inches i can't
remember
so he's okay he's good he's healthy i'm
good i'm healthy
i think he's he's frustrated because he
wants to eat so the thing is too like
we've been trying to breastfeed but it's
a new it's a new skill he's never done
this before so he's like kind of like
pushing out
the nipple with his tongue and like
trying to look for it and then when he
gets it he like pushes it out
trying to figure it out he's trying to
learn so we haven't latched on yet but
hopefully
really soon we'll latch on and he'll get
some breast milk also my my milk hasn't
really i haven't felt to really come in
with isaac it was like immediately like
instant like he latched on right away my
milk was like flowing like crazy
so it's definitely different but yeah
he's he's going with the murphy's law
even with breastfeeding case is your
name murphy are we gonna name you murphy
mom cutie
i see your face in him a lot yeah huh i
see it just looks like your family you
look so much like isaac to me
my
mother now it's so wild
you're a little brother
to isaac
i said your big brother now that's so
crazy
24 hours ago
you decided
today it's going to be your birthday i
want to just until his birthday oh yeah
that's right that's right literally the
only celebrity birthday i've ever known
my entire life is january 31st justin
timberlake and now that's my second
son's birthday that's crazy happy
birthday baby you still don't have a
name
yeah i call the name
it has been 24 hours now it's 6 30 now
um
in the morning so it's 6 30 uh
it's been 12 hours since the water broke
yesterday
what did i say
you're delusional
i've only slept one hour in the past 24
hours and you slept two hours oh yeah
i'm pretty
pretty tired but so much adrenaline and
so much it's hard to sleep like the idea
of laying down
doesn't seem very fun right now it's
definitely not fun for me because they
gave me more pitocin so i'm getting
cramped like crazy but it's really nice
to have baby on my chest yeah i'm so
proud of you
thank you tiff did amazing like pardon
me was like
you know ready to hear
our safe word we had a safe word to um
just in case
yeah she wanted epidural there's just
too much pain part of me was like
expecting it but then
the other part of me was like rooting
for her to like go all the way through
and you did
so
yeah i never even thought of the safe
word
that's awesome it took 20 minutes from
the time that i had my first like
oh my gosh this is intense contraction
to when he was born
exactly to the minute 20 minutes now the
trick is
to name this baby what makes it easier
now we whittled it down to only boy
names before we're like man this for
this
for the past nine months we've been
going okay we gotta have a set of girl
names and a set of point names so many
girl names yeah girl names are easy to
come up with like we liked a lot of girl
names but boy names nothing really like
you know just didn't really feel that
connected to i don't know we thought
that we would find something once we met
him yeah and now he's here and we're
like
uh what's your name yeah so we had like
24 hours to figure out a name for this
baby
because the
birth certificate peoples or whatever
like that process is gonna happen
by then so we have 24 hours i'm less now
because it's already a
couple hours have already gone by you
entered the world through such a
beautiful morning good morning
hello
you're so
tiny can't get over how much you look
like your brother
it's just like isaac he looks like
isaac look asian
yeah we're talking about you papa look
how hairy he is look at that look at all
this hairy peach fuzzy
cute little hands look at your hands
this tiny little face tiny little fuzzy
face look at
[Music]
them like he's gonna smile i think he's
gonna have more of your features than my
features
all right it looks seems like it boys
usually look like they're moms true
if you have a little girl next
you'll be seeing your little clone
hey
what's up
hi
he's just so spaced out
he's like bro i'm so tired
[Music]
photo shoes
[Music]
all right daddy's gonna change first
diaper brick poopy it's called meconium
meconium first
rookie mistake would be to not do this
which is to cover you want to try to
warm it up a little bit in your hands
that's the first working message
just kidding
really have daddy clean you up oh this
stuff is
yeah it's
doc
it's his first poop it's black where are
they feeding you in there in the womb
[Music]
all right so it's been about
almost four days now at this hospital
and her baby has jaundice
and so that's why they have put him in a
machine that gives off a uv rays it
basically like simulates the sun and
that will help the jaundice go away like
certain levels the bibli
bilirubin will go down i had darndest
growing up isaac had a little bit of
jaundice apparently it's predominantly
uh in asian people and in hispanic
people so little boy here's got the best
of both worlds
and luckily we just heard news that we
can go home today so
baby only has to be in here for uh one
day total whereas my story was i was in
one of these things for like a whole
week and so my mom had to go home
without me and and that was like really
tough on her at the time but yeah we get
to go home today see his brother meet
his cats i am so delirious tiff is
delirious and uh we're just super super
tired for like a 48 hour window i only
had four hours of sleep i had to go home
and like run errands like upload stuff
for big mood or like you know pick up
some extra things from the house because
we didn't bring it i was i was going to
sleep i was dozing off at the wheel so i
had to drink some coffee which i had i
had to break my streak as i i didn't i
haven't drank coffee in like i don't
know like up to almost a year now i feel
like
more than a year i broke my streak drank
some coffee caffeinated coffee because
i've been drinking a lot of decaf i just
like this flavor but i think it was
needed so yeah that's the update
we also have another update you want to
give them the big update by monday
morning oh no tuesday morning we're
supposed to come up with a name for the
baby we didn't we don't have it we
didn't have a name we had like options
but we just didn't know what it was
gonna be you wanna you wanna tell them
yeah so we officially decided on his
name and it is luca
so we have a baby boy named luca and the
way we came up with this name was
because out of the list of girl names
that we loved our most favorite name was
luna and so we were thinking how can we
come up with the boy version of luna
and we were like well let's just switch
out the n for a c and we have luca even
though we came up with luca there were
still a lot of other boy names that we
were kind of considering like we weren't
super married to luca yet and so these
past couple of days we've been trying on
all these different names that we had
just to see which one felt the most
right like the one that felt the best
and
it's just that's his name it just felt
like his name was luca um he also has a
chinese name i'm gonna give it a chinese
thing yeah his chinese name is tin long
tin long which is sky is 10 and long is
uh
means bright smart so together it means
like sky's the limit and you know this
kid's gonna be able to do anything he
wants in his life yeah so mama and papa
chan gave luca his chinese name
and so they said that they said we
intend for him to be happy
and bright his limit is as big as the
sky so that's what tim song kings which
is really sweet we like it we like it a
lot
so luca tim
or tintin for short another
good update happy one is my milk came in
so we've been successfully breastfeeding
now we did have the formula that we were
having to give him
because he needed to be well fed in
order to get rid of his jaundice as well
so
we had to
give him formula a few times during the
time that we were feeding him formula i
was also like trying to pump and
stimulate my milk to come in because
because of the fact that he came so
early my body wasn't ready for it they
were like
boobs were like no hold on we don't we
don't have milk in here yet but now
it's here um and i have my milk so i'm
really happy about that so i've just
been breastfeeding him
so
yay
so happy
everything's good high five
you've been great by the way thank you
just been doing such a great job i'm so
proud of him like seeing
seeing how um he's so intensive and like
learning it's been a huge learning
process and um i'm enjoying every step
of it i don't know i just feel really
proud i feel extra proud for tiff i
can't i can't express enough of how
proud i am of like i feel like i feel
like it's like a rite of passage and for
tiff i know like you know having gone
through a c-section with isaac i think
she's always felt like regret or like
like it was that opportunity was taken
away from you yeah kind of like uh yeah
it was like robbed from me the
experience of being able to bring my son
into this world the way
my body was designed to do it but yeah i
totally want to do like a whole sit down
and tell like the whole birth story kind
of thing because i have a lot of
emotions about it a lot of thoughts
because i have it like so vivid in my
brain and my emotions of like this birth
that yeah i want to talk about it yeah
super proud of her she fought for it and
she got it and
i don't know just so happy
this is like one of the happiest days of
my life i mean wedding day was great but
this one really kind of bumps it off
that the top spot
pretty easily the wedding day was like
titanic this is kind of like avatar just
like
it has to be movie
i love it
we're going home luka
we're going on
oh
look there's a milk didn't drink i know
but i made that i did it
[Music]
you